so you're looking at the weather before
you go fly and something doesn't look
quite right with the weather report you
just need a little bit more information
about the weather so you can make a good
decision and avoid hazardous weather the
perfect tools to help you do this are
called pilot reports or pi rips these
are reports that other pilots give to
atc when the weather they're expecting
doesn't quite match up to the weather
reports
in this video i'm going to show you how
to find these from your official weather
source which is aviationweather.gov and
how to decipher them because it can be a
little tricky to read
as soon as you open up
aviationweather.gov you'll notice that
the map here on the home screen has a
lot of different symbols and colors on
it if you scroll down below the map
you'll notice that these are mostly pi
rips and you can see here that there are
basically three different types
turbulence pirates icing pirates and
other weather pirates we need to click
on the individual pyrip to find out what
it is but these symbols represent the
severity of the weather the pilot's
experiencing as you can see the severity
can be nil light moderate or severe now
in case you didn't know nil just means
no turbulence or icing maybe the
forecast is calling for moderate
turbulence but a pilot flew through that
area and didn't notice anything this
would be good information to know okay
before we break this information down
let's look at one more way to get these
pirates because you might find this a
little more useful let's go up here to
observations then click aircraft reports
as you can see we have the same reports
but now we've got an option down here to
type in the center airspace we'll be
flying in now this is something that a
lot of instructors don't teach but you
need to know it because you also need to
know it when you're checking notems as
well
this is a map of the air route traffic
control centers or artccs these are the
identifier codes for who owns the
airspace you're flying in now when you
talk to these center controllers in this
airspace you'll just refer to them by
their name for example this zme area is
owned by memphis center
zfw is owned by fort worth center and
when you look in the chart supplement
you can see who owns the airspace you're
flying in as you can see at veneto
municipal airport it's owned by kansas
city center but these secret squirrel
codes are nowhere to be found in here if
someone from the faa is watching this
i'm begging you to put this map at the
end of the chart supplement because
pilots need to know these codes and that
would make it a lot easier to find them
and as i said earlier not only will you
need these codes to find pi rips but you
also need to know them to find center
nodems until they add this map somewhere
easier to find i recommend taking a
snapshot of it with your phone i'll also
put a link in the description where you
can find this thing okay so now that we
know the artcc we need for the airspace
we're flying in we can go back to
aviationweather.gov and type it in here
where it says center id now just like
all the airports here in the continental
us to get the right data you have to add
a k so if i want to look at memphis
center's pyrips i'm going to type in
kzme remember this artcc thing it's
going to come back when we start talking
about nodums as you can see we've got
some distances to choose from i usually
just keep it here on the 200 statute
mile selection then i'll click get
reports and now we're looking at all the
pirates in the memphis center airspace
okay before i explain how to decode
these pyrips i do want to point out that
there's a handy document that explains a
lot of what you might see on a pyrip at
the end of the chart supplement after
you watch this video you might want to
take a look at that okay let's zoom in
and talk about how to decipher all this
chinese gibberish let's start with the
first column the first three letters you
see here is the closest large airport
where the incident occurred this makes
it easy to quickly determine if there
are any pirates near where you're going
to be flying next we have the letters ua
which lets you know that you're looking
at a pi rip i'm not really sure what ua
stands for but i like to think of ua as
a usual advisory because if you ever see
uua this would indicate an urgent pi rip
and you'd really want to pay attention
to one of those now we see the letters
ov which stands for over this is the
spot the pilot was flying over when he
gave the report as you can see these
locations are usually given in radial
dme from different vor stations in other
words this pirate occurred on a zero
nine zero bearing from the memphis four
tech and it was 25 miles from the
station
this pirate was given directly above the
memphis 4 attack on this third line we
see another radial dme example when i
say radial dme i'm specifically talking
about their bearing from something in
this example this aircraft's bearing
from this location was 130 degrees at 35
miles the first three numbers indicate
the bearing and the last three represent
the distance ehr is henderson airport so
this aircraft was on 130 degrees bearing
from the airport at 35 miles and now we
know exactly where this guy was when he
made the report by the way if you're
still a little confused on the whole
bearing thing i explained it in a lot
more detail in my video on vor
navigation also that link in the
description if you want to watch it
after this next we have the letters tm
which stands for time this is the time
the pirate was given in zulu time for
example this pirate was made at 1038
zulu and this one was made at 1042 zulu
after that we have the altitude that the
aircraft was flying at when they made
the report and all you have to do here
is add two zeros to see what that is the
first one we see here is forty thousand
feet
this one was at four thousand feet and
this one three thousand if for some
reason the altitude was unknown you'd
see
f-l-u-n-k-n and of course this
weird-looking code would be on here when
i'm trying to sound cool in a video i
looked around at a few different places
and i can't seem to find the official
answer but i'm pretty sure it stands for
during climb out here's another one that
looks kind of weird and i'm pretty sure
this one stands for during departure now
if i could get a weather expert to
confirm my suspicions in the comments i
would really appreciate it but based on
the type of pirates that they are and
the pirates i've given i'm pretty sure
i'm right about these okay so next the
tp stands for type of aircraft as you
can see here this aircraft is a boeing
757 and this one is a crj7 this is
extremely important to keep in mind
especially when you're looking at
turbulence pyrups if a boeing 757 is
reporting moderate turbulence i
definitely don't want to fly my cessna
152 through that because that would
probably be severe or even extreme in my
airplane and that could completely rip
us apart and it's extremely difficult to
fly two airplanes at the same time now i
know we can't make it up to flight level
four zero zero but pilots report
moderate turbulence at low altitudes all
the time okay so now we start getting
into the three different types of pyrips
turbulence icing and other weather
conditions let me refresh the screen and
see if there's some new pirates i'm
making this video while i'm deployed so
it's really early in the morning in the
states and there aren't a lot of pirates
yet here we go so after the aircraft
type we can see a few different things
the letters s k indicate sky conditions
so we're looking at cloud reports here
as you can see these are very similar to
taps and metars because you have to add
two zeros to these numbers to see where
the clouds are but these numbers are in
msl not agl because pilots typically
glance at their altimeter when they're
reporting these clouds to atc so for
this sky condition report the basis of
these clouds are at three thousand feet
msl and the tops are at four thousand
five hundred feet msl so this is a
pretty thin layer
now with these sky conditions there are
a lot of different things you might see
you might see multiple layers reported
or you may just see the bases like we do
here as you can see here the bases of
these clouds are at 1400 feet msl and as
vfr pilots this is the most important
information for us because we need to
know if we can legally fly vfr
if we look at the airport on the map
you'll see that the field elevation here
is 472 feet msl so if we subtract the
field elevation from the base of these
clouds you'll see that the ceilings here
are at 928 feet agl and since kmwa is
class delta you're not going to be able
to legally take off vfr from this field
and this is what makes these pyrips
super handy because the metar might be
calling the ceilings at 1 500 feet but
if i check the pirates and see this
report i'm not taking off vfr or you
shouldn't be doing that anyways now
you're starting to see why these can be
super helpful in addition to that the
sky condition can also let you know when
the sky is clear i've looked at a lot of
taps and metars that were reporting
ceilings of a couple hundred feet then
walked outside to see the sky was
crystal clear sometimes those clouds
move out way faster than they thought or
the weather just didn't do what they
expected it to listen to me trying to
convince you that the weather forecast
may not be accurate you probably know
this way better than i do okay so
something else you might see on one of
these is a wx and after these letters
you would normally see a report of the
in-flight visibility this would be
indicated by the letters fv followed by
the visibility in statute miles so in
this example the pilot is claiming that
his in-flight visibility is 10 statute
miles
fv99sm lets you know that the in-flight
visibility is unlimited and in addition
to that you might see reports of rain
snow and other types of weather with the
standard weather contractions if you're
a regular viewer of this channel you
know that we've already talked about
those quite a bit in the past oh boy we
all know what this one means now but
i'll spare you this time the next type
of data that you might see typically
comes on an icing pyrip when you see a
ta this lets you know the temperature at
that altitude in celsius so in this
example the temperature reported by this
pc-12 at flight level 2 1 0 was a minus
15 degrees celsius the m here stands for
minus then as you might have guessed
this is an icing pirate because this ic
stands for icing and it looks like he
was picking up trace rime icing that's
probably not a big deal to him he
probably has anti-icing equipment but i
don't particularly want to fly through
any icing in a piper cherokee so if i
could even make it up to flight level
210 without passing out in a cherokee
this pirate might be of interest to me
now i don't want to spend a bunch of
extra time talking about it but there
are a few extra contractions you might
see with the icing reports clear icing
can be particularly scary especially if
it's moderate or severe like you see
here you may also see a mix of the two
or even this neg for negative if the
pilots didn't notice any icing just be
careful with this one if the forecast is
calling for icing and the pilot doesn't
notice it right here that doesn't mean
the icing doesn't exist it might be
severe clear over here and this guy
picked up nothing because he went
through a hole in the clouds another
code you might see is this wv this one
stands for wind velocity and this is red
just like you would expect in this
example the wind velocity is 270 at 35
knots too easy next we have the
turbulence pi rip and to make things
simple you can find this with the code
tb this can come in a few different
flavors a lot of times the pilot will
only report the intensity as you can see
here the pilot only reported light
turbulence down here the pilot reported
light to moderate turbulence then some
of these guys are reporting a smooth
ride so that might be a good altitude to
cruise at delta guys love giving smooth
ride pirates so if you want to work for
delta someday you should probably start
making those on the radio but anyways
with these turbulence pirates you could
see anything from light moderate severe
or even extreme now i've had my share of
moderate turbulence and even a little
bit of severe but i definitely never
want to experience extreme turbulence
you may also see turbulence reported
with the duration for example you may
see intermittent occasional or constant
now if the pilot experienced the
turbulence at an altitude other than
where he made the report you would also
see this in this section in this example
this pilot experienced light chop from
flight level two four zero to flight
level two seven zero so once again i'm
not super concerned about this one in
the plane i'm flying today next you may
see some remarks at the end which would
be indicated by an rm
now there's a million different things
that you might see in the remarks but
one of the main things i'm concerned
about is information on hazardous
weather like this one llws plus or minus
15 knots surface to 300 feet this stands
for low level wind shear and this can be
some scary stuff if you don't know it's
there you may also see things like this
which would indicate mountain wave
turbulence or even notes about the
braking action on the runway that might
be nice to know about if you like being
able to stop after you land okay now
that i've shown you the hard way to read
all these i do want to point out that
you can click up here on the format and
change these to a decoder view and as
you can see these are a lot easier to
understand now up here they have the raw
pyrup text and below that we have the
dakota view if you're wondering why i
didn't leave with that it's because i
wanted to boost my watch time a little
bit but in addition to that you might
get asked this on your written exam and
personally i think pilots should know
how to read these pirates because quite
frankly they come from us and speaking
of that if no one makes these pilot
reports then they don't exist for other
pilots to use so if you experience
something worth reporting let atc know
also as i briefly mentioned earlier at
the back of the chart supplement not
only will you find this handy sheet for
deciphering pirates but you'll also find
the pirate forum which helps guide you
through the information hcc needs to
make a good pirate as you can see they
have to have the first five lines of
data then the next information you
provide is dependent on the weather
you're experiencing for example let's
call it memphis center and give them a
turbulence pirate memphis center skyhawk
3148 x-ray pi rip skyhawk 3148 x-ray go
ahead with report this is a routine
pyrup i am 25 miles directly south of
the batesville airport kilo bravo victor
x-ray at 4 500 feet msl in a cessna 172
i'm currently experiencing occasional
light to moderate turbulence in addition
to that it looks like the base of these
clouds are about 5 500 feet msl when you
make these pilot reports you're going to
mess up but if you forget something
don't worry atc will ask you for the
information they need to complete the
report and the guy that's about to fly
through that area will thank you when he
sees that you took the 30 seconds it
takes to make the pirate and we're all
safer because of it i hope you learned
something today that will make you a
better pilot if you want to keep getting
better try this video right here and
i'll meet you over there